we're over here coming up with reasons
why the Niners got screwed like a
25-point welcome to Sims and love go
everybody started yeah we're started you
don't got it in your ears that's also an
idea yeah no we're going through because
I don't know if you guys had the same
experience we did yesterday where there
was like 13 games at one o'clock it was
the first time in a few weeks where I
think I saw 14 seconds of Broncos bang
yeah I saw the least of for sure because
I kind of wanted that game going Jeff
Driskel isn't gonna do anything yeah I
mean like it's actually we should do
that you should be like one word
association for all the one o'clock
games alright you want to create a game
right away yeah I guess so it's stupid
alright go you go first
Ravens Hawkins you're a legend
bludgeoning that was the word you've
been using all day yes you can jump on
it if you want all right
Rams Lions Gough was off bad right
that's that would just be my trying to
why we're going to say I was gonna say
deceiving to see if they won by 14 but
it really supposed a seven point right
Cardinals Packers sad Wilkes Wilkes
Wilkes
I went sadly as it was I wrote down in
my notes at one point of the game
Aaron's Aaron had one where he rolled
out left on a bootleg right and there
was nobody there yeah nobody there and I
was like this is the exact same play
where he threw the deep ball in the
playoffs against the Cardinals but
nobody was there yeah do you know what
the word is symbolic symbolic yeah right
you're right you're a microcosm yeah
yeah I mean seriously but yeah okay so
that's a good one
Jaguars Colts ah over-aggressive Oh
Colts yeah I'm the betting thing just be
like be per to realize that a field goal
can let you win Indianapolis exactly
like Sean Payton built bail you win the
game just win it and realize going into
that game no pain should kick a field
goal on Thursday night yeah you're right
but like you you realize you're going to
play the Jaguars without Leonard
fournette
and Cody kessler's the quarterback so
instead we're going for fourth and one
on the
right and then another fourth and one
when they are in field-goal right on 19
right so it was dolphin but I just liked
is that like be prepared to win the game
12 six bills dolphins Chow and he was
incredible what's freakshow bears Giants
Oh fluke yeah I mean I just watched the
film it was lucky yeah yeah I think
that's fair to say
Chiefs Raiders o Chiefs Raiders mmm I
want to I'm almost want to say like wait
what do I want to say their best worst
performance I've ever seared something
like that there's no it was my home
still had some unreal throws though
Panthers bucks ah self-inflicting Tampa
yeah messy gross every time I looked up
a I was thrown a frickin PO my gosh
yeah Jets Titans who cares Jets that's
all I could say uh usually should just
finished Vikings Patriots as expected I
found that the Vikings got screwed on so
many calls in that game did you feel
like it I did I felt like there was a
number of pass interferences that were
not called on the Patriots yeah there
were certainly some questionable ones
like which led into Belichick telling
Adam Thielen to [ __ ] off shut the [ __ ]
up yeah I like that there was a few
games I felt like refs played a little
bit more of a part in the game than they
should have a lot of people tonight and
last night too
that's the second time that a false
start has gone uncalled and led to a
touchdown for the Chargers against an
AFC North team this season last time it
happened somebody got fired
alright we're doing all of this and we
need to get to the main story let's get
to it
Simpson left cause a new rap anthing
right we do new rap anthem yes okay we
had somebody that put together a rap
song and it's fantastic okay but that's
coming up at the end of the sheriff's
honorable saying that the actual news
story yeah them at one Aaron Rodgers
there's a quarterback we've ever seen
right but it's happened it has we have
been together now for near for around
four years right the entire time talking
about how basic the Packers
offenses and how its held Aaron Rodgers
back after the game a loss in a game of
which they were favored by 14 points at
home which they shouldn't have been out
in the snow against an Arizona team with
a rookie quarterback and not a lot going
on anywhere else nope
they lose the game the offense look
stale the entire time and one of the
longest tenured coaches the NFL Mike
McCarthy is fired soon after yeah
thoughts on the timing I mean the timing
I was a little surprised it happened
yesterday I'm not gonna lie I mean I
understand where people are coming from
like I was sitting next to Tony Dungy
when it happened like I understand the
old-school nosov like this guy won a
Super Bowl he's been here for a long
time it's nine playoffs in 12 years like
you let him finish out the year but from
a business perspective I don't think
more say exactly right for both parties
yes Mike McCarthy can go do interviews
right now
yeah and move on and they can start to
work the back channels of talking to
agents and figure whether they want to
go after this is there's a lot of things
in our podcast that are coming to
fruition this season yeah it does seem
that way
Packers coach is leaving right Oh Dell
Beckham got his contract right Blake
bortles got benched yeah like the things
that we've been preaching now for years
I are actually coming to a head the
Odell one felt satisfying yeah Blake
bortles being benched did not right it
kind of felt weird like I felt guilty
yeah right Mike Marth Mike McCarthy
being fired how does it make you feel to
get back to word association yeah mmm
there's a little bit of like a I'm happy
in the big picture but I'm not happy for
the immediate future just because like
watching Aaron Rodgers in December and
meaningful football games but you know
this is what's drug this on anyways is
the fact that we've had to relax and all
these end-of-the-year flurry finishes
right to get into the playoffs or be the
succeed and Rodgers has continually
saved the day as far as that's concerned
and I want to say got my wish here but
finally got to the point
you know I at the end of a few years
it's just like damn I mean 2015-2016 I
was hopeful good thing they got Aaron
Rodgers they didn't have him that nobody
would be going to the playoffs McCarthy
wouldn't have a job and after last year
seeing what they really were worth
without Rodgers going six and ten and
then this year right injuries okay
played some undermanned football teams
at times that still shut down their
offense people can say what's wrong with
Aaron Rodgers all they want yeah is he
playing a Plus+ Aaron Rodgers football
no but see that's the problem it always
has to be a plus plus plus Aaron Rodgers
football or they can't win if he plays
an a- game they lose and it doesn't
matter who it is the arizona cardinals
whoever it may be he couldn't make magic
happen because they had speed pass or
good pass rushers who could disrupt him
from taking all day and dancing around
they have a good one you know pure shut
down cover corner and then they have a
Steve Wilkes who just like we saw
McDermott right same school of thought
where if you can get pressure with your
front four and we just keep seven in the
back end we will be all over these
elementary concepts of the Green Bay
pass offense and that's what you saw
once again I read this article from
Kalin caller came out four days ago in
Sports Illustrated called how it all
went wrong and Packer how it all went
wrong
wrong excuse me and there was one
section that explains and should explain
to everybody why Mike McCarthy was gone
and why we've been saying this for the
whole time I'm gonna read to you because
there's no way you've seen yeah no I
have not I've heard about this a little
bit on setting now on Saturdays before
games McCarthy and Rogers go over which
place Rather's Rodgers likes and wants
to keep and which place he once cut from
the game plan right though the two meet
individually three to four times each
week during the season a source close to
the quarterback says that because
McCarthy has other duties as the head
coach
he misses several offensive install
meetings or quarterback meetings a
source of frustration for Rogers because
McCarthy will add or change place during
the Saturday walkthroughs that mess with
the established flow of the game plan
right Green Bay's number-two quarterback
deshaun Kaiser and third
string quarterback Tim Boyle do their
best to patch up any disconnect during
games as part of their roles as backup
they both work to improve in-game
communication between the head coach and
the starter Kaiser and Boyle act as
translators hmm so what you're having is
you're having an upper level mind in
Aaron Rodgers sitting there all week
trying to create a game plan as any he
probably reads stories like Drew Brees
and Sean Payton staying there for hours
afterwards what do you like what do you
not like what can we work on and instead
his head coach goes I gotta go do head
coaching stuff right totally fine but
then I guess there's no check-in period
and then he's putting new stuff in in
Saturday while Aaron's already built out
more stuff on Thursday and Friday and it
leads me to this dilemma yeah Aaron
Rodgers is very intelligent
right do you give him somebody that's
equally or more so intelligent on the
offensive side of the ball or do you
give him somebody that is special
defensively special teams wise
overarching and that's gonna give him
another offensive mind in addition to
that guy right because I believe the big
issue with Mike McCarthy was I'm gonna
handle some of the offensive play
calling
yeah but I'm not at Aaron's level
anymore and I'm not giving it the same
attention right so is it better in your
mind to give him an offensive guru for
him to work with or a defensive guru
that will let him do these things no I
think he needs an offensive guru okay
yeah I do because again as you see why
I'm saying I totally I mean I think is
he's very he's getting the half-baked he
was getting the half-baked well you have
the during your week as being a
quarterback you have certain questions
you go okay we're gonna run this play
here and you want to go wait wait coach
but what if they do this I saw them do
this on film and if your play caller is
not there in the room with you to
discuss this and then bring up some of
the you know conundrums you might have
as far as evaluating the other team and
just questions that pop into your brain
like who this might not be failsafe this
play against
this defense I watched earlier today on
film those things don't have resolved or
yet you'd like the head coach to earlier
offensive play caller to be there to you
know conversate sometimes they think it
out you have a conversation he goes you
know what hey quarterback you're right
we can't do that because if they run
that so but my main answer to your
question which is a very just question
is that Aaron Rodgers doesn't know what
he doesn't know yet he still needs
someone to teach him man how are Brady
and Brees and Phillip Rivers throwing
these people wide open over the middle
15 and 20 yards down the middle of the
field six seven times a game how are
they getting open because there's so
many things that these teams are doing
that are not even involved in his
offense so that's where I would go back
to that so I have my top five list that
I have for you okay I like it because a
lot of times I ask you to do stuff yeah
I think the pressure should be on me too
okay the problem is is that my numbers
three through five right
we're not offensive guys yeah okay so
all of these the last three are coach
with OC yeah okay which means going out
and getting someone special right I'm
gonna say this on all of my coaching
staff Alex Van Pelt is on the coaching
staff Alex Van Pelt was Aaron Rodgers
quarterbacks coach that apparently was
let go because he was too chummy with
Aaron Rodgers and it made everyone else
feel uncomfortable right if you have a
guy and he's the guy right and the guy
has a guy right you don't fire the guy
of the guy yeah you just don't yeah
don't question it it's the guy's guy
number five Vic Fangio with OSI mmm-hmm
this is a guy that constantly dials up
but he's gonna need an OC first question
for you is is Alex Van Pelt OC worthy or
is he just the QB guy to be in there
with Erin Ryan I don't know if he's OC
worthy either I think he probably needs
to be a guy that needs to get around
somebody one other idea maker to kind of
expand his his horizon as far as
offensive play calling my number for
yeah I like the Vic Fangio thought
though that's a good one
my number four is Brian Flores okay OC
yeah
be flow be flow could bring in Chad
O'Shea from from the New England
Patriots whose the wide receiver coach
who is rumored to be the OC last year if
Josh did go to the Indianapolis Colts oh
well done for you so far I'm very
impressed you liked that one I do like
that one I like the Vic Fangio one two
and number three it's got to have that
offensive guy my number three yeah John
Harbaugh with OC yeah here's my reason
hmm John Harbaugh also brings special
teams yep John Harbaugh is also an elite
operation runner 10-4 and he's someone
that I believe can look at Aaron and go
I can make your life easy yes he's gonna
need that OC too right
but I feel like John would run the
Packers better than Mike did yeah I
would agree with that too I mean John's
a phenomenal communicational
communicator been around him he's got
great charisma and he can keep it real
it doesn't matter of your T sizzle or
Ray Lewis or you know the holy Christian
abiding left guard he can talk to you
and make you feel like you're important
so you like that one I do I like it
you're on fire kid my number to number
two is Bruce Arians the reason is it's a
personality match yeah but it's only a
personality match if it's really a match
right we all know Bruce Arians history
Andrew Luck Peyton Manning Ben
Roethlisberger his ability to work with
quarterbacks no matter where they're
from no matter how they are and he's not
a [ __ ] liar I don't mean to curse
there no that's all right but he's like
Shawn paid he makes buddies at the
quarterbacks and you're in the fight
with him he feels like he's playing with
you and I believe he's more advanced
offensively than Rodgers has ever been
definitely not but I do think Aryans is
going to need someone else and I don't
know if he's well they can leave Mike
paedon they can feel good about that
Bruce Arians of Mike penton's not bad
good work and I also think that air that
Aaron's is gonna come in that first day
and go Aaron we're gonna do this moment
yeah don't do this right and my number
one is josh mcdaniels yeah of course
because it's when Tom Brady goes he'd be
throwing for 7,000 yards in this offense
well guess what I'd like to see him in
the offense Yeah right
you know I'd I mean hey I'm with you
it's of course where my mind goes right
off the bat when I heard the news I just
went you know I think josh mcdaniels is
very cozy in New England I think he
likes it there he really plans on being
there but the funny thing is even though
he spurned the Colts last year and I
know some people don't like them around
the NFL whatever else man there's two
spots that are I think will hit home
with him again I haven't talked to Josh
in Cleveland yeah I mean I just think
both of these a younger quarterback
right and he's from Cleveland he grew up
there so that's the first thing I look
at there and then Green Bay you know hey
we all know anybody that's involved in
football Green Bay is kind of like the
holy grail of NFL football it's a
special place publicly owned right ADM
is incredible one of the original teams
really right I mean you got Vince
Lombardi Titletown
just the history behind that
organization job you're probably gonna
be the head coach there for 15 years
they're certainly not gonna rush to
judgment after two or three you're
exactly right um good good good list do
you like to listen what was interesting
I went through all of college and I said
they're not worthy of Aaron no I went
through a bunch of coordinators and I
thought they're not worthy of Aaron yeah
and that's the funniest thing is it's
like I'm picking out dates for my son
yeah I'm looking I'm like you're not
good enough for Aaron right and I'm
looking at the bet so bet DSi sent me an
email and I'm the gambling you are the
gambling guy they sent me a list of the
favorites and the number one favorite
right now is John Dee Filippo at two to
one is that right doesn't make sense to
me one I never bet on the favorite
there's some waste of money
josh mcdaniels is 2.25 to 1
you know who is in third at five to one
this was a name that was sixth on my
list didn't make the top five they're
coaching right now though Adam GaSe Wow
I don't think Adam GaSe has done enough
to warrant another team poaching him but
he's another guy in the Bruce Arians
mold that quarterbacks love working with
they do and he knows a lot more he is
like a little bit more advanced than
Aaron Rodgers offense right but I don't
think I'd have them at five to one I
agree okay I'm with you I don't
understand the default bow when I think
that's way to rush to judgment they
explain why because he's at the top of
every list on the Internet yeah I don't
really get that at this
point I mean again so Minnesota's
offensive decline this year we're gonna
just all blame it on Kirk Cousins
but John D philippa who takes over as
the OSI we're just gonna go nuts not his
fault it's only the quarterback that's
the only guy
listen points again something he does
some good things in his offense he must
be an incredible interview well he's a
great dude he really is he's a man's man
he has the persona to be the head coach
gotcha so but again I just don't think
he's earned the right yet to be the head
coach of the Green Bay Packers and Aaron
Rodgers and for Green Bay fans I would
argue too it's gonna be very similar I
mean it's a really a very similar system
he's got a little more razzle-dazzle and
window dressing but the base premise of
his offense is stove that too close to
Mike McCarthy fur for my liking Jim
Harbaugh eight to one mm-hmm get out of
here Jim Harbaugh exactly Wow Lincoln
Riley ten to one Dave table 15 to one
here's a name for you yeah Zach Taylor
15 to 1 is he down in Miami right now is
the quarterback coach like are you like
are you kidding yeah Eric be enemy 15 to
1 Bruce Arians at 20 to 1 not bad odds
and the one I like John Harbaugh is at
40 to 1 Wow
I love John Harbaugh at 40 to 1 Wow
throw 5 bucks in there come out with 2
jeez seriously Pete Carmichael's at 20
to 1 yeah I get that can you explain to
me how the heat Carmichael has been in
New Orleans for what seems to be a
decade right in association with Drew
Brees and Sean Payton and not only have
I never seen him get an interview for a
head coach Chris I've never seen him
talk yeah and if you played an audio and
somebody went mana I don't know if
playing with Drew Brees I go I guess so
cuz I've never heard Pete Carmichael
talk you you would know who is he you
would know him if you've seen him he's
been there for a while he is you know
going back to what your conversation is
like Mike McCarthy being the head coach
and not being able to be in quarterback
meeting rooms see that's what you have
to have if you're Sean Payton so you
have to have that guy that you can go I
gotta go work with the defense today
we've led up 911 Pelt right right but he
looked just like McCoy did I mean
remember that last year
he's on the bench like mcveigh's but
okay yes I mean I think Pete Carmichael
I don't think he's been interested in
pushing himself into that conversation
until maybe last year for the first time
I felt like he kind of a guy we put him
out there as far as I know true football
guy like I mean I know he's loved down
there in New Orleans I don't know him
well enough to speak to his personality
to say if he's a head coach person I
know when I meet him I think he's a very
nice man yeah and if he's hanging her
Peyton you know that he's I got you got
some edge he's got something to him but
yeah yeah I mean I agree with you that's
another guy that I think of there I go
if he puts himself out there I gotta
think somebody's gonna dance with him a
little bit and bring him in and talk to
just if you're curious Sabin is 250 to
one mmm Urban Meyer is 500 to one Mike
Holmgren is a thousand to one and Brett
Favre is a thousandth of what urban my
early college football at this point the
other one I don't understand is the
Lincoln Riley thing okay get Riley at
ten to one Lincoln Riley I've heard it
always gonna go to Cleveland let me just
say Lincoln Reilly's are really good
football coach Lincoln Riley though
would be another guy that I would just
tell everybody he doesn't even know what
he doesn't know everyone I mean what do
you think about his offense I mean his
offense is good I've covered him when he
was at East Carolina in the offensive
coordinator there and I was just getting
in the business the offense is good but
it's not enough for the NFL I mean it's
not something revolutionary every week
no you know what we know who was
revolutionary who came in the NFL every
week Chip Kelly how did that work yeah
there's no revolutionary for college is
not revolutionary for the NFL yes I
agree no one matching yeah right and
they bring ideas to the NFL game this
read-option the Wildcat whatever it may
be yes there's certain aspects of it but
their depth the depths of their playbook
are so elementary I mean I did Lincoln
Riley even know how to run an i
formation fullback offense doesn't even
know a lot of people would say Hugh Sims
do you need to run an eye formation with
a fullback I mean yeah I mean the the
second best team in football the New
England Patriots just smashed it down
the Minnesota Vikings throat doing that
kind of stuff yeah but no yes I do think
there has to be that
if you think you're just gonna drop back
and throw it every play and just tear
the league on fire I mean just don't
think that's the truth unless you get
Patrick mahomes and Tyree kill and all
these people on the same team she was
talking to Howard back right Jason Kidd
got hired as a head coach right out of a
Jersey yeah Derek Fisher got hired right
out of a Jersey yeah because they were
trying to find the next Steve Kerr yeah
right now in the NFL we're trying to
find the next Shawn McVeigh right and
there's this notion that if you're young
right
you'll be great the guy I don't see that
right I'm just gonna tell you yeah
realize when you have an outlier in your
face yeah Shawn McVeigh is not the norm
he is the exception there's a reason why
he stepped into people's offices and
they went holy crap a tornado just swept
through and I don't know how to react
but he's 30 years old and my brains
telling me I can't hire them Shawn
McVeigh is special they don't come
around you don't need to go and the true
thing is I looked at all these names and
I I don't really see any that get me too
excited no unless you go and steal some
I think your top five is as good as it
gets
really I do all right but who in your
gut who do you want Rodgers to get yeah
yeah the whole Cleveland thing that was
interesting yeah I mean I do think you
know this is uh Josh who's from the
Cleveland area went to Mesilla Norm
Canton McKinley I can't remember but
it's like the one of the greatest high
school rivalries and all of football
they get like 40,000 people there to
watch them play at the end of every year
but he's he's all football he grew up in
that area so yeah sure he ran out on the
Colts I know but the Browns and Packers
are two teams that I think would make
him get back in the people are
forgetting now how many questions we had
about Andrew Luck before the year yes
right people right now you're like oh
you so great let me just tell you yeah
Andrew Luck didn't play for a season
could barely throw tennis balls weren't
you didn't throw the Hail Mary in the
first week and we were like oh this he
done to something wrong with them can I
get something off my chest
do you mind it's gonna require a lot of
me talking are you sure I'm fine okay
I'm watching the game last Thursday I'm
watching the Cowboys beat the Saints you
know what I'm thinking
you thinking I'm not even thinking about
how I predicted it yeah I'm not even
thinking about how we picked the Cowboys
to win the East you know what I was
thinking about Sims what's that
completion percentage serious I was
thinking about completion percentage and
interceptions right the kale and
wheatgrass of Statistics yeah because
those are the two things that drew brees
MVP supporters have been pounding down
my throat right interceptions and
completion percentage right because Drew
Brees doesn't make mistakes that's the
big difference
drew Brees doesn't make mistakes I want
to look at the losses quickly yeah of
mahomes and Brees right mahomes has lost
in New England yeah and in LA right
those two teams are combined twenty and
four right and by the way in case you
care they were both in primed game my
home's came from time Wow
oh we got a question mark bucks I mean
Brees right lost to the Buccaneers at
home right and the Dallas Cowboys on the
road yeah their combined 12 and 12 right
and if you want to say oh the defense
the Saints averaged 25 points in those
losses the Chiefs averaged 45 one of
those quarterbacks can blame his defense
they still put up 45 points in those two
games right Drew Brees has three games
this year Sims with less than a hundred
and eighty yards passing his TD to
interception ratio and those three rough
games six to three mmm
you know mahomes three worst games of
the year he threw less to less than 300
yards his touchdown interception ratio
in those games was 10 to 0 the truth
that no one wants to admit is that
mahomes is capable of things that Brees
is not and it makes them feel
uncomfortable let's I looked up some
next-gen stats because that's where they
love to go with Brees intended heir
yards looking down the field and trying
to make place mahomes is 4th breeze is
28th tied with Eli of course have I not
been saying that with eel
right longest grooves also having his
best completion what a year he's on fire
longest completed air pass right just
looking around the league the longest
throw down the field that was complete
mahomes v just over 60 yards bortles is
29th Osweiler is 30th breeze is 31st 45
and a half yards yeah mahomes has nine
games with a completion over 40 breezes
longest of the year in the air 45 and a
half Sims drew brees threw for a hundred
and twenty seven yards in that loss to
the Cowboys mahomes threw for 166 in the
second quarter of that loss to the Rams
what's really interesting Sims I lied
there was one other thing I was thinking
about in that Saints Cowboys game that
if the Saints really wanted to win that
game they need a quarterback like
mahomes that's the truth is that Brees
throws 1:27 and it falls apart and they
needed a guy that could create by
himself right and that's the difference
yeah mahomes is the MVP and I just
kindly ask you guys to push in your
chairs as you leave because it's not a
debate we don't need to make this a
meeting you can happily show yourself
the door that was a very well thought
out you're on fire today kid it's the
coffee fire I mean this very
well-thought-out argument and and and
again you know drew Brees certainly
deserves to be in the MVP conversation
what do you know that he's amazing
you're right we're not trying to be
haters we're just were we're fighting
against the narrative that he's the
slam-dunk MVP and he's the only thing
that's making the Saints go and I think
a lot of your stats back that up and you
know me I'm not a stat guy but you know
I just it's good to hear the stats
verify some of the things I say or talk
about whether it's you know short
completions all those type of things
hey he's really good he makes that
offense work but he's not the only thing
that's making that offense work and I
would say he's not even
most valuable person or player in that
offense a lot of a lot of the times and
that was a tough one the other night but
you're right
they made it to where it was gonna be
drew you're gonna have to make plays
you're gonna have to get out of the
pocket you're gonna have to make big
throws and Horst Dallas was awesome drew
was padding the ball more than I've ever
seen drew was looking down at the rush
more than I've ever seen I mean our
preview and prediction
yeah when I said that they face these
cakewalk defenses and then we're going
on the road against one of the best now
I will say this
those two linebackers Jaylon Smith
although lately banned arrests yeah I
didn't think they were gonna cover him
like that yeah and I do think that we
need to do a self Scout yeah because a
lot of people were asking for it I'm
sure sure are you willing to officially
do one with as far as like which one
neither one bandar ish come on yeah I
mean van Dhiresh is a freak athlete I
know that you know where I want to put
you out on the line I don't care it's AB
now you're not putting me on bust either
way I don't care I'm truly not I don't
take this scouting thing personal I know
that when I scout players and put myself
on a limb and say something about a
player that I'm not going to be right
about every part like like like Philip
Lindsay is leading the league right in
rookie rushing right over say Quan right
you call that no one else solid the
entire NFL miss thank you for trying to
make me feel good even tears give and
takes exactly you're not gonna be right
across the board yes Bill Belichick must
own Brady for five rounds right Vander
Esch the aspect where I was wrong about
Vander Esch is his toughness there's no
other way to say it I really thought he
was soft as baby [ __ ] when I watched
film I just didn't know I was good I
don't know this looks like concussion
protocol waiting for me he doesn't seem
like he really wants to fill the hole do
anything like that but instead we're
seeing like a faster Brian Urlacher out
there right now
I mean whoa there I mean just
athletically I mean I'm not saying he's
that Peyer yet but just the ground that
those two cover and that was Mara was
running for his life that's part of the
game too that's again to speak to your
point they took away half back choice by
chimera in the flat for five yards they
stopped that all that screen
to Ingram great you can catch it but
we're gonna attack your read the line of
scrimmage it's not gonna go up to
sideline for 20 yards wide receiver
screens on the outside oh yeah you want
to catch it well our D lineman fly out
there they're gonna get killed if they
want to cook keep calling that play so
they took away what I always call the
bullcrap plays of any good offense and
that's what Dallas did a great job but
Vander Esch yes I was critical of where
they drafted him I was critical of him
as a starting middle linebacker I was
critical when they first put him in this
year I thought man looks like Tarzan
guessing he's gonna play like Jane yeah
but he's looks like Tarzan and he's
playing like King Kong in the last five
years if I told you Shawn Lee wasn't
playing I would mark the Cowboys up for
a loss Yeah right they they are so ready
for him to move on yeah it's fine yeah
two things about Layton Mannerist one
when I see a picture of his neck now
that's when I go I should have known he
was gonna make because the neck is
insane it's wider than the head it is
insane second the the situation now
where when he makes a tackle they play a
Howlin wolf and he starts howling on the
field oh I'm so on board I need you
understand this games going on yeah and
my family and friends Sims
are messaging me I can't believe you've
become a Cowboys fan this is disgusting
I never raised it my dad's going I can't
believe I raised two cowboys right I'm
not a Cowboys fan I'm just someone that
likes to be right right a lot and you
could respect the way they play like
Byron Jones is a hell of a player the
way did he lie around just their
physical and it's just like they have no
regard for their body now the Eagles
defense is playing literally right it's
fun to watch it's refreshing this Danny
it is and that's the thing as you know
you were critical of Layton Vander edge
but now we're in a world where 2018 was
markedly different market ibly different
than 2017 where a linebacker like
Leighton van Dhiresh is so much more
valuable in one year yeah the amount of
that people are throwing the quick
underneath pet the underneath passes the
completion percentages the dump-off star
running back yeah right it's so much
more valuable than it is it really is
did we see any like fatal flaws in the
Saints no we did not
I mean if you want me to get into that
just real quick about what I saw in film
no there was no fatal flaws I'm not
sitting here going oh wow I mean again
there's not many teams like you're
saying right now that have the talent
that the Dallas Cowboys have to do what
they did I mean I watched that film and
I might be wrong by one or two here but
to blitzes the whole game by the Dallas
Cowboys - and they didn't come to the
fourth quarter so they only rushed five
people twice the whole game the rest of
the game was four-man rush with a few
three-man rush flipped in there from
when they knew was the obvious passing
situation and they dropped eight to
flood the zones or whatever else but
other than that they just said you know
what our front four is athletic as hell
and that's really where the Saints had
trouble it's the explosiveness of Dallas
where they struggled they weren't
overpowered they were more out quick by
the Antoine woods in the middle the
Malik Collins in the middle Tyrone
Crawford and Lawrence were amazing on
the outside but then you get into the
Benson myomas and the Randy Gregory's
and you react and their ability to stay
fresh is amazing yes when I looked at
who I was gonna pick to go far preseason
right I looked at defensive line depth
yeah because every year we pick I picked
teams like the Packers and they didn't
have the depth but I like the Texans and
I like the Cowboys because they each had
eight guys are ready to go I thought
that Eagles did but they got hurt right
you know who's about to make so much
money
DeMarcus Lawrence is 26 years old he's
playing on a franchise tag this year
right I mean he could be getting paid
more than Aaron Donald next year
he shouldn't be but yeah you're right in
the class but yeah by the way I didn't
realize Aaron Donald at 16 and a half
sacks right he's about to dance in
Michael Strahan ville here soon if we
don't watch out I think he's going to I
mean he's got a great chance he's every
time I looked up at the Lions game
yesterday it looked like he was in the
back he was I know there was one time he
threw Stafford so hard that I was like
that's unnecessary
yeah what am i doing ah wait so just a
few more things about the Cowboys
defense other thing to blitzes the whole
game right while so their front four
just said screw you were coming okay
that office guy that offensive line
right exactly and you know how highly I
regard that offensive line did they play
banner they did if I had to give them
bad nobody played horrible but hunger
their Center was abused a little bit of
times and German Bushrod who had a start
at left tackle he struggled at a few
times as well the other thing I thought
that was fascinating about the game I'm
gonna say it was a single safety defense
almost the whole game except for maybe
two snaps oh hi Cowboys the Cowboys
single you're telling me yeah they
weren't afraid of being beat deep they
wanted more guys on so you do exactly
right you need the corners to do that
right but they play three deep and and
man almost the whole game that's all
they ever did and you're right they
weren't gonna let the screens the short
passes outnumber them underneath to
where oh okay great we have two safeties
back I'm sure their stats and their
next-gen stats that you looked up showed
some of the things you've seen let alone
the defensive coordinators they're also
in a Rod Marinelli and Chris Rashard
have great knowing of the West Coast
offense Marinelli was there with me but
Jon Gruden right of course Sean Payton
him are very similar in their play
calling and then of course Chris Rashard
was up in Seattle with Darrell Bevell
who was also along those lines so yeah
that's what was amazing their ability to
not let any of the pick plays happen was
phenomenal they didn't match up with
Michael Thomas right they they just said
no cheedo be if he's on your side you
got a man up and Myron when he's on your
side and you got him too and they were
both Byron was phenom phenomenal they
both were phenomenal
it's the bet I think I'm not going to
support unless Jordan Lewis is good he
didn't he didn't get in much it's
Anthony Brown is there real radical guy
right 30 is a second it's a hell of a
secondary cuz the other guy opposite of
Xavier exam Ian 25 is you know the X I'm
blanking saving saving woods right and
then Jeff Heath is the other right to be
honest right Jeff Heath mix play he does
he does I've given him a hard time he's
he's pretty dim and we can talk all this
trash I
do not hate the Saints they are your
Super Bowl team yeah and I'm telling you
right now they're gonna win their next
four games they're gonna be 14 in - yes
they're gonna win in Tampa they're gonna
win in Carolina they're gonna beat the
Steelers at home and they're gonna be
Carolina again Carolina is like the
worst matchup for the scenes from the
Carolina yes they are you're right they
tear them apart every year the only game
I'm really worried about there isn't
even Pittsburgh
it's that Tampa Saints at Tampa it's
just remember they lost that game last
year because Tampa could've just
protected them they'd just go bull throw
it down the field it's all here Tampa
does it care Tampa's the guy that goes
up to everyone the bar and goes are you
single and it's like that's you've
already asked that person need to go
home AFC yeah a huge seismic shift in
the in the standings Chargers beat the
Steelers yeah Chargers are now nine and
three Chiefs are what
ten and two yeah Patriots are nine and
three right Texans are nine and three
yeah but the Chargers beat the Steelers
Steelers were whooping them the whole
game we'll put them I'm gonna be honest
when I started working on my mahomes
rant in the second half right I wasn't
paying that close of attention the game
was over I dare you I'm kind of curious
what the hell happened okay explain it
first thing is this I mean okay blown
opportunity I mean you're right
Pittsburgh dominated the first half they
should have been way more than what they
were up at that point all right first of
all karma we got to talk about karma
because karma came back to bite Big Ben
in the ass a little bit okay the game is
13 to 7 all right Heath there was a
horrible interception where he just lobs
a ball down the field I don't know what
he was confused I thought maybe he
thought German shits yeah whatever
so he does that pitiful mistake there in
scoring range there that hurts them
right 13 to 7 okay charge get the ball
okay not a big deal
Chargers punt the ball Steelers get the
ball they go right back down the field
yeah you know what happens that series
that was a series if you remember Justin
Hunter was wide open for the touchdown
and he missed the throw right Justin
Hunter hurt his shoulder on the play
they kick a field goal so it's 16 to 7
really at that point the game already it
should be 23 to 7 2007 whatever you want
to say there at that point so that was
their first way of letting them in
Chargers go on a good drive to start the
start the second half they do that okay
they get a stop on the Pittsburgh
Steelers what happens X punt return for
a touchdown
and kings of all so he is so there you
go from like I feel like we've said this
a lot lately where when you have a
chance to put a team away in the NFL and
you don't do it and you let them hang
around it just more times than not is
gonna come back to bite you in the ass
especially when that other team has
talent yeah like the Chargers just
Saints Rams and Patriots are the only
teams that do it in my book
yeah sometimes the Texans I'm not even
putting the Chiefs there because their
defense isn't good enough to put it up
yeah I think you said every team James
Ramsey make sure some Patriots yeah when
they get up yeah they they hold your
face yeah I think that's pretty fair
Pittsburgh has times where they can do
it but they have times like we've seen
the last two weeks or they let you slip
back in and do it too yes but I'm a
groove in there but Steelers and
chargers what does this mean for the big
picture um I don't know if it I love the
pressure keeps on the Chiefs I hear you
there yeah of course it is
uh I don't know if it changes any of my
overarching thought dealers and Ravens
are a lot closer than they were
definitely I mean hey the Steelers are
putting themselves at the spot where
yeah they're gonna have to beat the
Patriots they're gonna have to hope
somebody else loses a game maybe two if
they want that first-round bye but with
that loss last night I mean that pretty
much makes the first round by I mean
it's gonna be pretty hard to obtain that
especially with the tie on their record
so it's gonna be Patriots and then the
AFC West team cuz I can't even say
Chiefs right now cuz if the Chiefs lose
to the Chargers no I know it's even know
the Chargers the one thing I worry about
and I think the Pittsburgh dropped the
ball on this last night they run the
ball down the middle
they have no denzel Perriman no Corey
lujon no brandon me bein they got pass
heavy at times they did have some bad
calls go against them I mean [ __ ] Joe
Hayden's gonna intercept the ball in the
end zone and his own pyre knocks them
out and they hoard a touchdown yeah
that's what kind of night it was but you
don't put them away one weird bounce of
the ball it's 23 to 7 Joe Hayden's gonna
pick it do you remember the play yeah I
was gonna say is Jalen Saunders a better
option for them than James Connor
thank you I mean he's every bit as good
you know I like me I don't know if James
Connor would've got that edge yeah I
know
Jalen's Daniels you know I said him in
the oh we've just said his name two
different ways
shame jaelyn Sam Mills yo you sure I
call him Saunders no it's Samuel okay
you're right yeah I remember
trust me cuz I I had him with NC State
Notre Dame last year
he's so eat so jaylen Samuels and Naima
Hinds from the same backfield yeah with
Bradley Chubb ok NC State yeah NC State
Bradley Chubb BJ Hills on the Giants
right the other the other defensive end
got drafted he won that tore his ACL
guys work out team at Amherst right the
d-10 they're all for their D lineman
went but I didn't realize any those two
running backs to know I think Samuel
Sanders Samuel Samuel Savin Samuels can
totally fill that role he's the guy I
really thought would get more playing
time in the preseason if you remember
cuz I thought he was capable of doing
this the Steelers I wanted to say this I
meant to cuz I thought about just cuz of
our notes last week I don't think
Jonathan Bostick played him one passing
by last night but then I saw him say
Jonathan Bostick Pittsburgh's like I saw
him get in he was on the starting thing
but right any pass play I don't think he
played very much you know they put the
fort guy there 54 alright we're talking
about AFC running backs and the big news
that happened on Friday was Kareem hunt
he has been cut by the Kansas City
Chiefs I'm just gonna say this it's
incredible to me I go on the social
media and there's something about social
media I love with Simms and love Co
which is when something happens people
flock to ask us questions Mike McCarthy
fired our mentions blow up they know we
love Aaron Rodgers right when this
happened I can't wait to hear Sims and
left go steak I wonder what they're
going to say why are you asking me
questions that you already know the
answer to is it okay in any former
fashion to hit a female no no that's the
end of the story yeah I don't I don't
know what to tell you I think it's very
dangerous to enter a world where you
compare violence against women in one
video to violence against women in
another video that to me sounds like the
worst game to play ever yeah I don't
want to play that game yeah and so the
true thing is is I feel awful for all of
the parties involved
mm-hmm that were actually in the video
from the female to everyone but in the
end you don't got to ask me this
question you don't need to because the
answer is clear there's a No
tolerance policy and there should be
yeah because and look man when you do
your apologies and you say all that
stuff he's gonna have to wait a long
time he's got to look a lot of people in
the faces I'm saying I'm sorry yeah and
then once he goes through all of that
we'll see yeah it's gonna be on someone
willing to do it right but I just look
at it now and I go man he did it I got
nothing for you
yeah did it and then lied to the team
about it right so that's the kiss of
death the NFL too you know again they're
weird too and their whole due diligence
and these kind of they just do diligence
I don't know what they don't do any I
know I don't know what they do here but
I also think with like this and then
Reuben Foster last week to you know the
NFL needs to like you want to talk about
protect the shield like this is these
are two instances where yeah okay
protect the shield they shouldn't be
able to go on waivers or anything they
should be commissioner exempt until all
things are figured out yeah not a good
look for Kareem hunt and I'm certainly
you know a shame for the for the girl
and what you gotta go through there's no
easy way to transition to football stuff
after that conversation all right you
ready for some great moments in gambling
yeah all right I'm gonna like literally
pick a song on the fly so just put my
mic up if possible I have no idea what's
gonna happen okay that makes up all
right never mind screw the music okay so
great moments in gambling rams are up
seven the line is ten just over two
minutes left
todd gurley is running down the field
i'm high five and Josh Cohen and that's
a left go lock and he decides to run
along the ends in line luckily there was
a two-minute warning and some time outs
and they had to get it in the end zone
and it ended up I think being pretty
smart he wasted more time yeah but they
were able to get the cover I almost
freaked out yeah that would have been
crazy second great moment in gambling
from this weekend Jacksonville playing
Indianapolis first quarter Indy
field-goal nullified penalty on
jacksonville indie then continues to try
and score a touchdown
goal-line stand on the one another
fourth-quarter fourth down stand on the
19 yard line jaguars hold on and they
get the cover it was plus for those two
would have made it an indie cover right
now so those two goal line stands put
some money in my pocket right Giants did
you make that left colic
oh well suck I went 3-1 though okay good
for you this is the one I got wrong
Giants scored on a pick sick six an obj
50-yard touchdown and Taylor Gabriel
fumbled at his own thirteen yeah 17
points right there
Giants go on to get that win that is the
perfect example of when you bet on a
game and one team is kind of winning the
entire game but there's some other big
plays that over I know no longer getting
that win that was a bad moment in
gambling another one for you this is
this is an under-the-radar one
well the uncalled false start on the
Chargers right led to that touchdown
pass right Chargers go on to win ruining
the Steelers win and cover that play
doesn't have them but this was to my
gambling moment of the weekend you
didn't even realize if you weren't
paying attention
fourth quarter 12 minutes left bills
dolphins Josh Allen throws a 25-yard
laser-beam twos a Jones for a touchdown
and more importantly comes right back to
him and gets the two-point conversion
dolphins go down and score a touchdown
to go up by four but guess what that
two-point conversion gave you the point
to cover the four and a half point
spread if they go for one there you lose
your bet they go for two and get it you
win your bet Wow Josh Allen gets the win
and the left go lock for the Buffalo
Bills plus four and a half games that
was when your locks that was a big time
I'm just gonna say this
Josh Allen was the most entertaining
watch
of Sunday football Josh Allen ran and
threw for over 300 yards I think he ran
for 140 130 535
there was nothing open and I'm watching
this guy run for 40 yards I watched this
guy do the Chris Sims dipsy-doodle Carew
what do you do how do you do he spun
Kiko Alonso around right now I have only
seen Barry Sanders and Mike Vick do the
inside-out that causes people to spin
right and Josh Allen did that to Kiko
Alonso I get that he's not that accurate
as of yet I get that he throws balls
into some dangerous situation yeah but
Josh Allen is arguably the most talented
quarterback on a field not named Patrick
mahomes in terms of sheer talent right
now there's this special are you seeing
what I'm saying course I am yes I'm just
yeah I hope everybody else is seeing it
that's all I'm saying you know instead
of he's the only thing keeping them in
the game he's the only true threat they
have on the offensive side of the ball
yes it's not perfect but the reason they
be Jacksonville last week was because of
Josh Allen and the reason they were in
that game yesterday was because of Josh
Allen he was the only reason leer easin
I mean yeah the running game the
traditional running game of the Sean
McCoy it was not going to work yesterday
doesn't exist he threw the bad
interceptions to examine Howard I'd like
to remind everybody the xavius our
disraeli good okay but yeah it's
exciting and you could see why I was so
excited about him coming out in the
drafts I mean it the talent alone is
special there's not been a lot of guys
at that size you can run the way he can
run and throw it that way of course and
I think the things that we all had
issues with them those are the things
that if you made me have issues with the
quarterback that would be the issues I'd
want because you can fix those issues
all right ready layout of this yeah
fourth quarter the Dolphins have now
taken the lead 21:17
mm-hmm josh allen pitts makes a pass
five yards incomplete penalty we go back
to first down incomplete can't get it
going LeSean McCoy second and 20 on
Buffalo's 25
25 yard run by Josh Allen yeah first and
10 at the 50 26 yard run by Josh Allen
he's the only part of their offense that
makes any sense
right it's the only thing moving the top
10 longest plays of the day for Buffalo
38 the beautiful throw to Patrick -
Marco over the linebacker great - oh
yeah
28 Josh Allen run 27 a deep pass strike
to Robert Foster
26 Josh Allen run 25 the deep throat is
8 Jones on a line in between three
corners 25 another Josh Allen run like
he had four one two he had three runs
over 25 yards yeah Lamar Jackson didn't
have that against the Falcons no I know
this is why he was my number one ready
to quarterback in the draft he can do
things that the other guys can't there's
no other way to say that and we said
we'll see I know that the where it's not
all written out yet and I'm not putting
the stamp of approval but no again yeah
I think he'd be his number one y
receiver is a joke right
I mean weather's been amazing don't I'm
not trying to take away Baker or any of
that but still the guy that it's still
excites me the most is Josh Allen that
that I will not change the other guy is
Lamar yeah
Ravens Falcons when you saw the line go
to the Falcons favor you said this
doesn't make sense to me and I said the
only argument that I could make is that
the Falcons are gonna get the edge on
the Ravens right and if you remember
right you were pissed last week when I
said you go that doesn't make sense to
me like fine like you actually got a
little upset yeah you're right right and
the Ravens went out there and we said
the word earlier I blood [ __ ] legend
what did you say yeah I mean from get-go
I mean the first thing I wrote on my
notes here is when you turn on the film
the first thing you notice is how much
bigger the Ravens are compared to the
Falcons I mean when they went to the
first endzone shot of the film and you
could see the Lyman you know the offense
or defense yeah it's it's elena's
defense versus Baltimore's offense and
you could see Atlanta's asses you know -
to the screen and and and the Baltimore
Ravens offensive line are facing me I
mean there was a noticeable size
difference from get-go I just said whoa
I mean this is two different football
teams but
yes a bludgeoning I don't know other way
to say it this is one of the ass
whippings of the year really I mean
kinda I mean you just talked about it
what was the game you were just talking
about that the offense did nothing um
and I don't know why I can't Buffalo
Colts Buffalo maybe yeah maybe was there
Miami one but I mean the Falcons could
do nothing on the offensive side of the
ball I mean absolutely nothing other
than the five seven carries for 22 Tevin
Coleman six carries for eight yards
right Matt Ryan 16 completions for a
hundred and thirty-one and Julio Jones
leaves the games with eight targets two
catches 18 yards yes I mean so
conceptually wink Martindale they were
all over some of the things that the
Atlanta Falcons wanted to do in the past
game and the offensive run game forget
about it let me just waste everybody
even waste your time going back to watch
it it was just absolute Brandon Williams
Michael Pierce uggs Jude on just pushing
the Falcons offensive line back into the
backfield run game over Mike Matt Ryan
under duress all game long
whether it was blitz are just rushing
for there was people all around him the
uniqueness of the Ravens defense and all
the creative ways they find do rush for
and rush five and still play normal
coverages behind it but they make it
look like it was something crazy because
people are dropping in and out of the
line of scrimmage other guys are Blitzen
and it's only a four-man rush or a
five-man rush time of possession was was
39 39 to 2021 I mean they had the ball
for a quarter and a half more yeah it
was Atlanta forgot Atlanta's only
touchdown was the vic-20 recovery other
than the first drive of the game
I'm telling you the Atlanta Falcons had
a hard time passing 50-yard line Wow the
first drive of the game where they went
for a 12-play 49 yard drive 12 plays 49
yards to get the field goal was really
the end of their success of the day 131
yards I mean what was their total yards
out 131 total yards on offense for the
day well I'd like to also the last Drive
of the game was seven
five yards so you're telling me that if
that last Drive didn't happen when they
were already down 16 points and the game
was already in hand right that they
would have ended up leaving this game
with 56 yards they could do nothing so
when they played zone they were all over
their schemes when they decided you know
what we want to play man they went jimmy
smith you take Julio ha ha Humphries uh
is Humphries right yeah that rookie from
the second-year guy from Alabama Marlon
Marlon Humphrey you take Calvin Ridley
and our third corner will take some new
whom I miss him on young no I wasn't
tame young I hold on I wrote it down
here I got it's gonna drive me crazy
Smith I'm biking out on names today I
don't know what the hell is wrong with
me but either way it was shut down
session so when they wanted to go
man-to-man
Jimmy Smith was not gonna be overpowered
by Julio Jones or anything like that he
stayed right in his hip pocket let's
love me think about Vegas yeah Vegas
looked at this and said we haven't seen
Lamar Jackson on the road yet right we
haven't seen Baltimore as I said played
Cincinnati and Oakland haven't really
played a team not that Atlanta's defense
is that good it's really honest probably
worse than those other yeah Oh Brandon
cars the other corner everything else
yeah he played great yes Baltimore is
now seven and five yeah they're firmly
in the six seed above the mess of Miami
Indy Denver and Tennessee all they're
knotted up at six and six right what's
your level of confidence in Baltimore
now kind of confident I mean I just
think they're playing Baltimore Ravens
football it's kind of like this
old-school Nebraska wishbone Baltimore
Ravens football on the offensive side of
the ball but the base premises still
beat you up physically and then just
have a few little shot plays in the pass
game from time to time it's really what
they did early on a Joe Flacco's career
just kind of run the ball right play
defense Flacco will hit you for a
25-yard gain in the pass game every now
and then right
I know we'll be smart except this time
they're just doing it through the run
and then it's a design play-action pass
or something off I mean Lamar missed two
series getting examined for concussion
yeah and they still were able to win
this game by that much I mean look read
off their drives
off their drives and what they did I
mean so it's nine plays 75 yards for the
first touchdown of the day the next
field goal dried nine plays fifty nine
yards
the next field load drive ten plays 72
yards
the next field will drive 14 plays 60
yards the next field goal drive 13 plays
55 yards I mean you know what's funny
that's slow death the fact that they
were playing in Atlanta yeah it was
funny because there's something when you
have a very mobile quarterback where
there's these underneath passes that are
wide open because the linebackers are
too busy worrying about the quarterback
sure that every time I looked up on a
big third and four or third and five the
dump off to the running back of the
tight end Andrews was always available
yeah cuz Lamar would shift already
that's right the linebacker would move
with them and then the guys wide open
yes and it's an Atlanta where I watched
it happened so many times with Vick cuz
you're right I mean it's very similar as
far as that style of play especially
when they get on the run and the way he
flicks the ball but yes there was a
number of those type of completions
they're just straight ahead run game it
was just I mean they just moved Atlanta
every time Atlanta's just not big enough
to hang with these type of football
teams on a consistent basis so the
physical power of Baltimore was way too
much you know I love Gus Edwards Lamar
wasn't perfect in the game he was not he
missed some throws that I'd like to see
him hit he let his feet as we've talked
about for the like he at times can let
his feet get real close together right
where that's just a no-no at the
quarterback position it's not a baseball
right you see like you see Drew Brees or
Rogers or Brady that keeps us to my face
right always he will have times where
it's like he lets his feet get right
next to each other and then tries to get
back normal that's like baseball
throwing you don't do that with a
football right so then the ball the ball
ends up going where he doesn't want it
to go for the most part he still threw
the ball well though he doesn't make a
lot of dangerous place he really he
really doesn't he doesn't coached well
for ten weeks he really has and then
they they they do a good job of drawing
up a few shot plays for him to just
basically go hey we're gonna roll you
out to the right here and we're gonna
get everybody going
we're gonna have a guy run a post across
the its other side of the field and if
you could throw a good ball we got a 50
yard completion if not it's incomplete
we'll run the ball but run for seven
yards exactly right exactly right
I'm just looking at Baltimore schedule
right now yeah there's seven and five if
they end up nine and seven so two into
the rest of the way I think they're in
the playoffs yeah I don't see any of the
six and six team is really going on a
three and one run their remaining games
sure they have a game at Kansas City and
at the chargers but they have a game
home against the box in between them and
home against the Browns right they could
beat the box and the Browns at home the
city in Kansas City this week are you
telling me the Ravens can out Kansas
City Kansas City in Kansas City no I
think they're gonna have to Kansas City
in Kansas City they're gonna have to be
big-time Baltimore but right because
that defense against Lamar Jackson
they're not getting off the field I
don't think so
and Harrison buckers been missing kicks
or so yeah he has been Justin Tucker
does not there was it's I mean this game
was comical at points I mean there was
like eight people packed in between the
tackles right yeah and they they
couldn't do anything like eight people
packed out in between the tackles and
they were like okay we're still gonna
run it right up the middle for four
yards
oh you wanna you wanted to smash him in
there a little bit more okay there goes
Lamar around the edge so there really
wasn't anything complicated as far as
game playing they're doing a good job of
managing the game all around and Lamar's
not messing it up now the one area he's
got to be a little careful of is he has
had exchanged problems the last few
weeks like running the read option and
the ball pulls out now we haven't heard
about it because he keeps recovering
these fumbles but there was - last week
there was one right there was -
yesterday I mean at some point that's
going to come back and bite him in the
ass but for right now they're getting
away with that that makes me want to bet
against them with the cheese but let me
just make sure I didn't miss anything I
think you're good I think I'm good - but
I mean yeah I mean and then hey you're
playing Lamar Jackson and the Baltimore
Ravens like I mean I don't know do
something different change it up I don't
know they three deep zone the same
defense play after play after play
and just they were in their comfort how
can ya love for any consistent yeah
Giants bears yeah so you watch this film
oh my gosh what the quarterback play was
just atrocious both of them oh who was
worse I don't know
chase Daniel was worse that bad huh yeah
hey listen Chicago you need your Biscay
back okay it's two weeks of evidence I
mean it was just a full scope of Matt
Nikki's offense we've seen
whoopty-doo I don't know where to begin
on this one I want to start off as Eli
give me back next season I mean I
wouldn't I think you're gonna be waste
away years of this team being really Eli
Eli in the offense they were they were
embarrassing in the first half they were
and he was embarrassing I mean he just
he didn't want to stand in there make
one play they didn't want to do anything
I mean won't for me out right pocket can
be perfect and Eli will move out and get
jumpy for no reason yeah I can get hit
he'll he'll he'll get so nervous in the
pocket everything's perfect and he'll
move out of the move out of the pocket
and bring himself into dangers way it's
just um yeah it's it's frustrating to
watch them the Bears were clearly the
better team on the football field
I mean of course you have the pick-6
bioelectric go ahead keep reading in
just Eli should be embarrassed by first
half does nothing to help them just all
about managing his career yeah it's all
of this it's just let me get the ball
out I got a completion that's great of a
second and eight there was a guy open
for first and 10 15 yards down the field
but damn I might have had to get tackled
if I had to throw that ball so I'm not
gonna do it sake one Barclay is the best
running best running back in the NFL
nobody does more with less nobody better
than Gurley yeah better than Gordon he's
mean better than Zeke I've seen the last
few weeks I'm putting say if you gave me
my first pick of the draft the running
back position I'm taking exact one
Berkeley from what I've seen just I mean
you see what he does I mean he's he's
the reason they got you know he's just
he sets up everything for their football
team he's truly just a phenomenal
football player and of course what he
does in the pass game I mean the field
goal before the half so they're down 14
to 7 right
third and 2013 23 they run it up the
middle and he's got the whole Chicago
bear team around him the whole team
there's 10 of them around him he does a
hop a jump a skip skip it to the right
it almost turns the corner and gets 22
yards so they can go for it on fourth
and one and they get a 5 yard completion
I don't know what the [ __ ] the Bears
were doing they get the 5 yard
completion they kicked the field goal
now it's 14 to 10 Giants haven't done
crap the whole first half that was their
only success cuz Ogletree got the pick 6
I start the game they go in the second
half
their fourth play a reverse pass right
change the game 1740 right 1714 then the
Bears go three and out and they put
together one of their first drives of
the game to end it up in the one-yard
touchdown pass formation with Odell
exactly right yes is it crazy to me that
Odell flat-footed squared threw it
further and completed it than any past
that Eli has thrown this year here's the
two longest touchdown passes on the team
of the year right he is currently two
for two for a hundred and six yards and
two touchdowns he's a sick athlete man I
don't know what he was doing because the
guy was wide open from get-go I wanted
to be like throw it throw it hot cuz
from TV it looked like he kind of ran it
a little bit to make sure they came in
but they were already in like he was
yeah I was like cuz when I thought the
same thing on TV I was like what's he
doing oh you must have just wanted to
draw him up a little farther you're
telling he was wide oh my gosh from
get-go maybe got nervous but he might
have
I mean he's not used to playing
quarterback you do want to make sure you
see it clean he probably balls this
Europe and spot-on he's I mean we saw
him throw that ball in training camp can
he throw like 70 yards exactly right by
the way I saw an interview with Patrick
mahomes where he said the longest he's
ever thrown is 83 Oh 83 he's listen he's
having an off day I go 84 and most of my
days really no you wrote in there though
chase Daniel no pocket presents I don't
get to see the notes yeah I mean I know
at Monday I don't get to send the
picture of the notes to you just because
we're so rushed but you said he played
small and I can't throw with people
around them hey this is what we've
always done but oh wait I mean he can't
make a throw in the pocket I mean that's
all there is to it I mean it just
doesn't matter he can't throw the ball
accurately he can't throw it with any
pace he throws a wobbler every time
unless it's Tariq own running a wheel
route he can't really hit it and of
course
Tariq owned was open for four or five
wheel routes yesterday and a few check
downs and everything like that but
there's a reason that Tariq Cowan is at
12 for 156 and then they don't have
another receiver over 80 yards it's
because they don't have a drop back pass
game with that mr. burski it wasn't a
great drop back pass game with Mitchell
sure Biscay now it is severely hurt and
the fact they're missing tour bus keys
ability to run and escape the pocket and
make plays that way that's been a huge
part of the rawest your bears got
screwed you thought Cowan was not out
Cowan was not down on the long touchdown
he definitely was done his knee was up
they blew a premature whistle that
caught the cost I'm an extra four points
because they had to kick a field goal
that should have been a touchdown let me
ask the question that you wrote is your
last note made it how many times was
Landon Collins get burned by running
backs before they make a change I mean
make it what kind of a change well I'm
just saying like a schematic will change
like stop putting him in that position
he's obviously not capable of running
with a Tariq Coen in space on the
backside of a formation where it's just
he and that type of player one on one so
to me if I've seen that now for like
what we've seen that four weeks in a row
things like that against that liner
right it just becomes bad coaching
because now you're asking your player to
do something that he realistically
cannot execute and you're just taking
the Lee's lazy way out so yeah he's been
underwhelming this year I like Landon
Collins he's had a phenomenal career but
he has not played great football as of
late I want to read this out loud tariq
cohen since his bear mitzvah seven
catches 90 yards against the Dolphins
against New England eight catches 69
yards and a touchdown on 13 targets
against the Jets a 70 yard touchdown and
40 yards on five carries against the
bills he didn't play a lot because they
won 41 and nine against Detroit six
catches for 29 he also ran for a
touchdown
against Minnesota
seven yards rushing 23 yards receiving
not too much there
of still a Witten Detroit seven catches
45 yards in a touchdown and against the
Giants 12 catches a hundred and
fifty-six yards since he got his bear
mitzvah with Sims and Lefko of his six
touchdowns in the year five of them came
after the bear Mitzvah he is absolutely
destroying ever since we made him a man
yeah the mensch the mensch is the man
lehayim to you I feel like he took all
of the touches that Jordan Howard was
getting to yeah yes he has at least they
got back to Jordan Howard running the
ball though a little bit the last two
weeks and we saw it again yesterday the
Giants front and the inside interior
part especially with Olivier Vernon and
Olivier Vernon will never be the sack
master everybody wants him to be but
he's phenomenal football player and he's
very good against the run but with with
Tomlinson and BJ Hill in the middle of
Coe with Olivier Vernon and Kareem
Martin like the running was not there
down the middle anytime the Bears had
any success in the run game yesterday it
was bounce plays from the outside it was
oh he ran it up the middle they
collapsed it and they found a way to get
around the edge to make a run that way
but it was nothing just write down the
Giants heart as far as that's concerned
Odell on the onside kick yeah I got a I
need to watch that one on film my first
thought was he was way too far away okay
he was on the opposite side of the 50 so
that didn't make sense to me that means
he was more than 15 yards away cuz I
mean he was lined up incorrectly I mean
I don't know if he dinner
or they coach it that way either way
I'll say listen listen it wasn't a good
look for Odell I get that worse look
that or Cam Newton in the school
probably Cam Newton in the Super Bowl it
was a tough spot to you know you get
stuck in spots like this because you
don't know what to do either it's not
about like he's a wimp and he was scared
to go in there it was more like wait
what do I do here do I try to bat the
ball to where we all can get it do I
just dive in there
do I maybe this guy bumbles the ball and
then I get it you get stuck you get you
be shocked to how many things can go
through your brain and I would say to
you that that's what happens to us but
if you are the on
sidekick guy yeah I need the guy that
doesn't ask questions
it just dives in blind yeah and the guy
that just signed a hundred million
dollar contract is probably not that guy
he's probably lying back for the pop-up
ball yeah go up and jump over somebody
and secure it with your hands yeah the
scrounge in the pile guy maybe that's
maybe they saw him hiring she was
supposed to be that pop-up guy like
you're talking about yeah Bears went
let's kick a ground ball at the pop-up
guy it was a great kick I mean he had a
run up aggressively didn't even get
there so if you really look at it let's
be honest top spot should we be
embarrassed for another um sure yeah
hey dude you could have shown a little
more guts there but totally should have
broken your clavicle but you were still
awesome yesterday man you are awesome
Vikings Patriots is there anything you
want to touch on that from what you saw
um did you actually watch that I didn't
I watched it on film I'll have a good
breakdown for the Thursday pod for that
I'm very excited about yeah but still a
good game to watch I mean one of those
games where I don't know how you felt
but I was just like okay it's 10:00 to
10:00 in the third quarter so when's
doing I'm gonna win they gonna win by
ten or seven but is it gonna be always
14 oh I mean you just felt that way you
felt that again it wouldn't it was like
a microcosm of Minnesota again where we
just went can they make a big play to
drive the ball no yeah cuz that's the
only thing they can do they can't drive
the ball consistently it's always got to
be a big Dalvin cook run or it's got to
be a big throw down the field if it's
not that we're three and out how about
feeling and Belichick cursing each other
out I know what do you think I loved I
want to know what got well apparently
bright happen with Filan he was
complaining their breaths well the
reason was Minnesota went for it on
fourth and one yeah they a hundred
percent in my mind did not get in look
like it the Patriots in an attempt in I
guess in feelin's mind to slow it down
and a player went down Oh got you and
Filan said after the game oh how
interesting that right when you want
them to go and challenge something a
player mysteriously goes down so that
you guys can see more replays that's
apparently what he call
the Patriots for Belichick said why
don't you just go shut the F up yes
right but and feeling self if you look
if he hates me hates me I don't care I
just saw the two things together and
said that's odd yeah I love feeling now
yeah that's great on him it's also great
on Bill because he's got a fail-safe
plan if he hasn't seen the replay yet
he's tell somebody to go down and get
hurt it's like I had a famous coach one
time that Vegas dropped a big mf'er on
oh he did you're right he was like
you're because like I said I thought
there were a number of calls that the
Patriots didn't get called for right oh
yeah right I saw I saw one or two
certainly that word I see but the
Patriots are the page if they are the
Patriots I mean I think they're going to
be the number one seed and I think
they're gonna be a handful well just the
way they play right now let me see what
frickin odds they're getting it's Smash
Mouth like I don't even understand like
like when all that the Saints and the
Chiefs were getting up there like come
on yeah tell you that Josh get over
there was a coach this is a smart thing
where I'm not even gonna name this coach
but if you got a defense a touchdown
right in a game the next kickoff like
your defense just scored right it's been
on the field now it's scored a touchdown
now it's gonna be asked to go out and do
a quick turnaround right this coach
would make sure that somebody goes down
on the kickoff to by the defense time
and we'd have an injury timeout and go
to commercial NFL yep so I was with
three different teams I don't know how
many defensive coordinators you guys
figure it out of yourself like an extra
2-3 minutes just to give the defense
another right 2 minutes and 30 seconds
to catch their breath because they were
on the field pick six we celebrated all
the emotions are going and you don't
want them to go out there right on the
first play and all sudden BAM we get
gashed down the middle for 25 yard run
cuz our D tackles are still tired from
running down on the pick six or whatever
it may be Patriots are currently 5 to 1
to win the Super Bowl mmm I like it
yeah there are three Rams and say answer
at seven to two Patriots are 5 to 1 my
Texans 1601 whoa that's pretty good pick
your Texans
like I think of the number one team just
at this point right now if you made me
go who's one team in the AFC that you
think you could division going to do
winglet and beating New England in there
I would pick the Texans as my number one
team to do that I'm super happy yeah I'm
telling you when I looked at the season
I looked at strength of schedule
the Texans buy a lot of metrics had the
easiest strength of schedule which also
leads me to say that the nine and three
record is a little bit inflated the AFC
South is also having a down year but as
I said last week and I don't need to say
again they have all of the necessary
pieces right and I would also say from
this Brett this Browns game they got
like eight yards of carry every time I
looked up Lamar Miller was shaken a guy
at the second level right and when you
mix in the fact that they didn't have to
rely on Hopkins they didn't have to rely
on Demaryius Thomas there are multiple
tight end sets and red zone situations
had been super reliable Watson's not
having to do too much and most of these
teams are struggling to do anything
against them when their defense is on
the field man the defense is flying the
Texans legitimately have a home-field
advantage
yeah and what a pick by me it was a good
pick by you it was a great pick almost
as good as as bad as that Packers pick
was but the but but the both of yours
are still in it that's the game I was
disappointed I didn't bet more Texans I
just
I check in doubt cuz I've been burned by
the Texans I've picked them to be a big
bed game like three times this year in
the game ended up being close and I was
just like damn I just don't trust it
anymore
I like the Texans at home a lot you're
going to do this I'm ready to do this so
I actually want you Josh to do the full
intro because you've been doing the
communication on this okay so a couple
weeks ago I'm gonna come around swing
into the shot here if I can all right so
that's on that one know which one I'm in
the shot there I am okay yeah that's
alright okay so a couple weeks ago I was
in Austin Texas for our sales off-site
and I got a DM on Instagram from a guy
that said I work downtown I love your
podcast if you're hungry come by my
office we have extra food in the fridge
you guys haven't told me this story
right no we might have mentioned the DMT
yes but I ever mentioned okay so by the
time I got that DM I was already on the
flight so I was not
able to take him up on his offer to feed
me however he responded a few days later
and said if you guys are interested in a
wrap for your podcast I'm a rapper and I
would love to tape something for the
podcast so I said sure why not
he has been DMing me for a couple weeks
we've been talking and over the weekend
he sent me the final version of the what
we're gonna call the Sims and left go
anthem I think so if you're watching on
YouTube we're gonna I'm gonna put the
video over here this is the first time
these guys have seen this first Simpson
seen it I hope the audio is working the
audio is gonna be where I've seen this
you know the first time you're gonna see
it I just let it play okay just hit play
on that bad boy dream if you listen to
that they got the best part
some hustle never quite sleeping like
gin gee-gee
season here's a reason you should listen
every day
every plane ladies Sean McVeigh but in
the spread do whatever they say I'm
quite confident except the left relax
you should probably do the opposite on
top but I ain't afraid to say
[Music]
racist we think that everyone is the
greatest I'm debating
[Music]
that's my man
special guests they bring to sit up on
little bit I love that mask I saying
so hats off to the most authentic
Christians that door
haha
Bendrick hey [ __ ]
good km okay yeah so that is our guy
Kevin minor on Instagram he is at Kevin
underscore raps he is the man he I mean
let me break down his rhymes they were
really good they were good they were
action it was really that was a good
beat and yes incredible rhymes actually
you liked it I really did I was very
that's very impressive do anymore I love
them are our music and is coming from
Texas to covering the dirty house in
Austin good
just as we could where's Lucas where is
our guy from oh yeah rot Simba not from
Houston oh he's not Delaware he's not
from Texas now he's not Texas although
Lefko was the one that said he was yeah
he was I don't know why I saw the text
yeah but I don't want to take any of the
shine away Kevin and I score rap yeah
yeah our APs
the flow is great I really enjoyed it
yeah and the fact that you were texting
back and forth with Fenric means that
you're doing the hard labor but no the
whoa big offseason was amazed the left
go lock make sure like all of it that
was great my LinkedIn photo really well
really yeah yeah the fact that the last
word is fin during yeah let you know
maybe a minor but he's majoring in rap
songs good one there Sims good one there
awesome awesome awesome what part of
Austin's you live in you remember that's
right you were down there for like a
sales copy yeah that was when I was
taking videos of Mac and putting fake
photo room all right Houston people
asking if you're gonna go be Mac so see
in North Carolina oh sorry can't do it
captain not gonna have them the bar I
said if you don't get the Packers job
you might consider it if Aaron Rodgers
doesn't call me up to be a quarterback
coach I'm staying here sorry I couldn't
do college football Joe hey Jimmy Joe
come to our school I got great Jimmy Joe
we got great cleats and we got great
uniform and we love football here Jimmy
Joe let me talk to your mommy Jim Joe
Jimmy Joe let me tell you something when
you see the locker with your name on
that play right you it's gonna be the
same locker that had Jabril peppers
now I'm a Michigan first I'm gonna say
this for the last four not for less time
for the birdies Atlanta is going to be
fun
I'm getting DMS hey should I come should
I save up for the draft party no Atlanta
that week is going to be awesome where
we're having meetings on meetings on
meetings it's gonna be a great time you
come down and check out what we got
going on I mean we were hanging out with
Champ Bailey today
yeah you guys will hear that in a few
weeks but he's like oh I want to come
and see you guys in Italy yeah it's
gonna be a good time we are we're gonna
make it good we're gonna have some good
players come around we're gonna interact
with everybody that's there and have fun
so a good time just Wednesday Thursday
Friday I don't know probably doing some
Tuesday I told you guys the plan like 15
times Mondays in Atlanta so we're doing
that for sure he has no idea oh I know
oh he knows Josh knows magic Mondays
let's wrap this podcast up deal alright
so coming up you're gonna look at some
film
yes YouTube we're gonna ask the question
is there any film that you'd like some
yeah wow me what to watch I'm sick of
figuring that myself I'm gonna watch
Texans Browns for sure I'm definitely
gonna watch Vikings Patriots before I
third floor guys it's the chime in yeah
but please Jamie maybe how did
Jacksonville hold the Colts to zero
points
seriously that seriously alright for
Simms peace out homies Hendricks says
good evening everybody lef koe man says
holla holla holla and by the way if
you're over the age of 18 go listen to
Method Man by Wu Tang and understand why
I say my name even I didn't get it not
that I listened to the song this weekend
and I was like M ETH OD man and it's
amazing so go listen to it
peace well see you soon